jetzt finden wir mal reden haben vor
drei jahren schließlich auf die
schlagzeile älteste primarschülerin der
schweiz
es hieß eine 35-jährige peruanerin
besucher in der kleinen gemeinde vor dem
wald die dritte klasse wohl aber nicht
mehr lange denn dies widerspreche dem
schulgesetz
[Musik]
mich interessierte etwas ganz anderes
wie um alles in der welt landet eine
erwachsene peruanerin in einer aargauer
primarschule
dies ist die berührende lebensgeschichte
von norma ammann
seit 2008 war die peruanerin mit hans
ulrich ammon verheiratet er war fast
doppelt so alt wie sie ihre biografien
hätten unterschiedlicher nicht sein
können wurde heirat war norma ammann
eine klassische so papier
die als touristen in die schweiz
eingereist die legal hier geblieben war
[Musik]
hans ulrich ammann hatte es anfang der
90er jahre als wunderheiler zu
bekanntheit gebracht er war ein star der
branche
damals lebte seine jetzige frau noch in
bitterer armut in peru die note jener
jahre hat sie hier eingebrannt noch
heute besteht sie darauf das nudelwasser
nicht wegzuschütten sie ist es als suppe
der 66 jährige stand im telefonbuch noch
immer unter praxis für
gesundheitsförderung und lebensberater
klienten hatte er nur noch selten
[Musik]
hans ulrich ammann war schwere
diabetiker und fast blind
er träumte von einer frau an seiner
seite die sich liebevoll um ihn
kümmerten seit der scheidung von seiner
ersten frau lebte er lange alleine
[Musik]
bevor sich die beiden kennenlernten
arbeitete norma ammann versteckt bei
einem schweizer paar als haushaltshilfe
sie lebte mit der ständigen angst
entdeckt zu werden und träumte von einem
sorgenfreien leben
was sind schon 30 jahre
altersunterschied wenn man mit einer ehe
nicht du die liebe sondern auch ein
besseres leben besiegen kann
[Musik]
in der coop zeitung gibt es an essen von
männern die frauen suchen
ich habe fünf ausgesucht und mich bei
ihnen gemeldet
hans-ulrich war der erste der angerufen
hat am anfang bin ich sehr erschrocken
denn er hat mir gar nicht gefallen hatte
so an bord
[Musik]
für mich war das nicht einfach aber ich
hatte es satt wir gerade in der schweiz
zu sein ich wollte endlich legal hier
lieben kino nicht spanisch kann daher
als relativ schwach können unterhalte
und da schau mit der grund sie wollen
sie denn relativ rasch mich entschlossen
hat spanischlehrer und und erklärt
intensiv und dann ist das natürlich
immer besser gegangen und zählt denn
auch genau aufklären
so haben wir dennoch herangegangen ist
mensch und auto mal spanisch noches
[Musik]
allemagne et al j entlang
ja
wenige monate nach dem ersten treffen
heiratete das paar in peru hans ulrich
ammann sah zum ersten mal cusco die
heimatstadt seiner frau sie ist für mich
die schönste frau der welt und die
liebenswerteste frau der welt
sie gefällt mir sehr ich hoffe wir
werden ein glückliches leben haben
[Musik]
als ich klein war träumte ich davon
einmal zu heiraten und viele kinder zu
haben
hier in der schweiz sind die männer aber
sehr speziell
sie suchen schöne elegante und gescheite
frauen
mich würden sie nicht mehr beachten
darum habe ich mir einen älteren mann
gesucht und ihr mann ist er nun der
traummann den sie gesucht haben
er ist ein sehr guter mann einer der
mich liebt und mich anbietet er gibt mir
seine liebe
er ist ein engel ich hole ich mir als
hans ulrich ammann erfuhr dass seine
frau nie eine schule hatte besuchen
können schickte sie in die dritte klasse
alle im dorf waren sich einig auch wenn
erwachsene eigentlich nicht in die
primarschule gehören musste man eine
frau einfach unterstützen die seit ihrem
sechsten lebensjahr als verdingkind
geschuftet hatte man hat mich verprügelt
hat meinen kopf immer wieder an die wand
geschlagen
wie bei einem huhn haben sie meinen kopf
unter wasser gedrückt
im haus in dem ich gearbeitet habe war
so ein großer wassertank
eines tages habe ich ein glas
zerschlagen
ich war sicher dass sie mich deswegen
umbringen werden darum bin ich abgehauen
weit weg zu einer anderen familie
der sohn ihrer neuen arbeitgeberin
bedrängte sie norma ammann brachte ein
kind zur welt das nicht gesund war
geld für einen arzt wählte
die mutter des kindes vaters hatte schon
kleider gekauft für das baby und sagte
sie hätte kein geld mehr
zuerst habe ich dem kind die brust aber
irgendetwas wollen nicht gut
ich hörte auf zu stellen und gab ihm
kuhmilch doch das baby ist gestorben
der mann hatte niemanden der ihr
beistand in ihrer trauer und
verzweiflung
es ist schmerzhaft darüber zu reden
sie schlugen mich andauern und sie
sagten mir meine eltern hätten mich bei
50 rappen verkauft damit sie mich
endlich los sind ich brauche ein
taschentuch
anfang 2011 wiesen die aargauer behörden
norma ammann von der schule erwachsene
gehören nicht in die primarstufe fertig
doch wer die peruanerin etwas gelernt
hat dann dies man muss er sein glück
kämpfen
[Musik]
cornelia flure ist primarlehrerin und
arbeitet als hausfrau sie bot spontan an
norma zu unterrichten bis eine neue
lösung gefunden ist
ich finds lässig das neue meisterwerk
leder noch erholen braucht man
grundlagen ist ganz klar
[Musik]
gerade fünf stufen ist die stufen drei
stufen stufe stufen
stufen ist schmal namen hat ein besseres
leben gesucht
ihr mann hans ulrich eine frau die ihn
liebevoll umsorgt in der kleinen
gemeinde vordemwald hatten sie sich
gefunden
jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch eines
zum perfekten glück
ich glaubte es für den kinder kommen
aber sie kamen nicht
wir werden wohl nie kinder haben
vielleicht ist es weil hansueli nicht
gesund ist im leben zählt das kleine
glück mehr als die großen träume und mir
schien was habe normal man dieses glück
endlich gefunden
hans ruhiger mann war am ersten august
2011 gestorben
[Musik]
ich konnte nicht glauben dass er tot ist
zwar sehr traurig und sehr schmerzhaft
es ist hart ohne handschuhe er fehlt mir
ich vermisse ihn sehr denn er gab mir
alles der 66 jährige war schon lange
gesundheitlich angeschlagen
doch sein tod kam für seine frau völlig
überraschend so überraschend wie die
nachricht des arztes sie erwarte ein
kind als hans ulrich ammann star war
seine frauen zweiten monat schwanger
die ausnahme ramba nada gott hat mich
nicht verlassen
er hat mir ein kind geschenkt bevor er
hans uli zu sich geholt hat
[Musik]
er wollte dass ich mich nicht verlassen
fühlen
[Musik]
william andrina man geboren am 20
februar 2012 benannt nach dem eleganten
englischen prinz william
[Musik]
ich war mir absolut sicher dass ich
keine kinder mehr haben und alleine
bleiben würde
[Musik]
ich wusste nicht dass ich schwanger war
fühlte mich einfach kraftlos antwort ich
sagte zu mir wir müssen zum arzt gehen
er hat uns dann mitgeteilt dass ich
schwanger sei hans willi war sehr
glücklich als er das hörte der arzt
sagte zu ihm sie bekommen ein kind aber
nur eines und ich sagte 1
wie ihre zukunft aussieht weiß norm aber
noch nicht
erst einmal dreht sich ihr ganzes leben
um den kleinen will i am
[Musik]
ich habe keine angst ich bin ja hier mit
meinem söhnlein und nicht in meiner
heimat peru
[Musik]
alles wird gut gehen und ich beschütze
ihn wenn er geschlafen hat ist da immer
so hungrig
nach dem tod ihres mannes zieht norma
ammann in diese kleine zweieinhalb
zimmer wohnung mitten im dorf ihre
freundin cornelia fluri unterstützt sie
bei administrativen angelegenheiten die
witwe muss ihr ganzes leben neu
organisieren zusammen mit cornelia fluri
geht sie von einer behörde zu anderen
und füllt unzählige formulare aus heute
steht die verlängerung von norma ammanns
aufenthaltsbewilligung anfangen muss die
peruanerin nicht mehr sie dafür immer in
der schweiz bleiben
mit handys und fahren zum rocken
unterrichtet dass sie mal die zahlen
gemacht hat er schon für relevant sie
zahle ich mag mit 20 sago nach dem tod
von hans willi das mit glatten müssen
anstatt berkeley lehrer und und
rechtslehre eigentlichen beruf auf
frische und voller erlebnisse die sache
machen
norma ammann führt ein einfaches und
zurückgezogenes leben
sie hatte eine bescheidene witwen und
waisenrente und sie bekommt
unterstützung von den menschen aus dem
dorf eine nachbarin etwa schenkte ihr
baby kleider
technisch schwierig geworden
schwierigere wieder wenn man mit dem
partner zusammen mit der haut hinein
findet aber standen sie da finde ich
jetzt rein tut und es ist ja das kind
wird den durch in der kategorie zu hohe
danke das ist für mich normal chance für
ihre sprach und für die integration da
cornelia flure ist die gotte des kleinen
billard ii ist der mann von hans-ulrich
ammanns tochter aus erster ehe
ein kontakt der norma ammann sehr
wichtig ist die peruanerin lebt seit
vielen jahren hier tut sich aber immer
noch schwer mit schweizerdeutsch
obwohl sie schon lange unterricht nimmt
einmal in der woche besucht norma ammann
den mutter kind deutschkurs
[Musik]
ich gucke nicht lange und kuchen
der chor verließ
ihrem william bietet norma ammann das
was sie sich hart erkämpfen musste ein
unbeschwertes leben in würde
norma ammann geht ihren weg unbeirrt und
leise
und eines tages wird sie ihrem sohn die
geschichte erzählen wie um alles in der
welt sie als erwachsene in einer
aargauer primarschule gelandet war
[Musik]